oh this year's Oscars won't include a
popular film category like the Academy
once proposed but many of your favorites
will still be there campaigning for an
Oscar takes a lot of work but nothing
like the work that went into actually
making the movie from groundbreaking
visual effects to daring stunts to
layers of makeup there's a lot to admire
from this year's Oscar nominees here's
what 2019 Oscar nominees look like
behind the scenes
[Applause]
few movies in the last decade have
altered our culture as much as black
panther dated in 2018 it's showing at
the Oscars proves that it took
blockbuster filmmaking to new heights
the movie involves a lot of demanding
stunt work from the cast for each
intense fight scene yes
tonight Carrera really did use a wig as
a defense mechanism and yes Chadwick
Boseman did kick a guy across a field
with the help of a few wires meanwhile
Michael B Jordan went to set everyday
and was covered in around 3000
prosthetic dots makeup artist Joel
Harlow told us the fake scars were made
to withstand the actors more physical
scenes as well as the ones where he got
wet and a studio in Atlanta was
convincingly transformed into a Conda
that space came complete with bustling
city streets and a waterfall that would
become warrior Falls
horror movies are often overlooked
during awards season but this box office
and critical success was too impressive
for the Oscars to ignore while the movie
produced scares from its lack of sound
the wieszczyk did you sound were
impressive
the film's sound team use a strange
array of objects to make Foley sound
crab legs perfectly captured the sound
of the monsters walking a combination of
celery and romaine lettuce would make
the sound of an ear opening to figure
out the monster spine-chilling
echolocation sounds the team did some
experimenting and discovered the best
way to do it was by tasering a patch of
grapes and then slowing the sound down
there'll always be a place for period
pieces at the Oscars the historical epic
centering around Mary Queen of Scots and
Queen Elizabeth the first and starring
Margot Robbie and Saoirse Ronan is
notable for its costumes makeup hair
pieces and sets the movie was shot on
location around the United Kingdom in
Scotland the stars acted with a literal
army of extras
[Music]
the favorite plays a bit more fast and
loose with history but it still
flawlessly immerses the audience in 18th
century British aristocratic life the
costumes and wigs are eye popping and
elaborate the movie was shot at Hatfield
house in England they stripped many of
the beautiful rooms in the palace and
built a massive bath as well as
Abigail's room
[Music]
the reception of first man which
chronicles Neil Armstrong's trip to the
moon was mixed but one thing nobody can
deny is that it's visually stunning it's
set pieces are as historically accurate
as possible production designer Nathan
Crowley told us that the lunar module
and space capsule were built to scale
meanwhile the Saturn 5 model seen in the
movie was actually just 14 feet tall
that's about 125th the size of the
actual rocket some of the models could
even move in some scenes to convincingly
replicate zero-gravity they put the
camera below the actors a technique that
has been used in many movies set in
space the moon landing sequence
just shot in IMAX will actually make you
feel like you're walking on the moon
some parts of this sequence were shot in
the quarry other parts were shot on a
very convincing looking soundstage the
stunts are equally impressive Gosling
allowed himself to be launched out of a
capsule and then got dragged around in
the movie's most daring stunt
[Music]
what sets a star is born' apart is that
all the concert scenes were filmed live
and Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga
are always performing together even for
two people as talented as them they
still had to rehearse a lot a big part
of the production was sound editing
which required layering multiple sounds
in a single scene including the vocals
all of which were sung live
[Music]
wes anderson's ii stop-motion animated
feature was one of the best animated
movies of 2008 teen it's staggering just
to look at the numbers behind the movie
Isle of Dogs animators were working with
around 1105 puppets on set a single
sushi-making sequence when the movie
took six to eight months to bring to
life
animators meanwhile had to use pins and
wooden sticks to move the dog's eyeballs
and lips around to make the characters
move realistically the animators even
painstakingly move the fur around to
give the impression that dog's fur was
blowing in the wind stop-motion
animation requires phases to get changed
out for each different mood and emotion
and ijen the head of the movie's puppets
apartment told us that the characters
fur made this process much more
difficult than usual
[Music]
Marvel's most ambitious movie yet didn't
quite get the same awards love as Black
Panther but it still managed to make an
appearance the biggest standout
technical aspect of the latest Avengers
was Josh Brolin's towering performance
as Thanos the actor performed in a
motion capture suit for a character who
would then be created using CGI because
Thanos is so tall brawlin often acted
with an object on top of his head that
way actors would know where exactly they
should be looking motion capture
technology has gotten so good that
Thanos felt real
honestly it's about time the Academy
starts taking motion capture
performances more seriously
[Music]
the long-awaited sequel involved a cast
of very committed actors meanwhile
production designers created a very
accurate version of 1930s London inside
a studio for this shot in which Mary
Poppins falls into a bathtub they built
a giant slide beneath the tub that Emily
Blunt had to slide down backwards
[Music]